produced with exclusive support from
Bavarian Nordic and dendron throughout
our lives the cells in our body grow and
divide but when cells start dividing and
spreading uncontrollably they become
cancerous there are more than 200
different types of cancer and scientists
are continually developing and testing
new ways to treat them most cancer
therapies involve drugs designed to kill
the rapidly dividing cells this is what
chemotherapy does but there is a
different approach called immunotherapy
immunotherapy uses the body's own immune
system to fight cancer this involves
activating immune cells and getting them
to recognize the cancer tissue as
different from normal body cells this
isn't easy but recently the field has
had some success the FDA has approved
several new drugs and with more drugs in
clinical trials some say we are entering
a new era of anti cancer immunotherapy
the idea goes back to the late 19th
century to an American surgeon named
William Coley he injected bacteria into
tumors and watched them shrink the
bacteria it seemed were provoking an
immune response but our immune system is
highly complex and for most of the 20th
century scientists struggled to turn
Coley's observations into effective
cancer treatments but after decades of
learning about the immune system a
variety of immunotherapies are finally
making their way to the clinic we can
divide them into four general strategies
nonspecific immune stimulation adoptive
cell transfer immune checkpoint
blockades and vaccination strategies the
first nonspecific immune stimulation is
used to give a general boost to the
immune system in vivo to do this some of
the many cells that make up the immune
system such as these antigen
presenting cells need to be activated
researchers can do this by injecting
molecules that bind to receptors in the
cell membrane the activated cells then
alert other immune cells such as these T
cells T cells are the main players in
the fight against cancer when activated
they can attack and kill tumor cells
for full activation small cell signaling
molecules called cytokines are needed
two cytokines interferon alpha and
interleukin 2 have been developed as
drugs and approved for use against some
forms of cancer including melanoma
another way to stimulate immune cells in
vivo is to inject bacteria like William
Coley did this has led to a rather
surprising use of the BCG vaccine BCG is
normally given to children as protection
against tuberculosis but scientists have
found that the weakened bacteria in the
vaccine can also help patients with
bladder cancer the bacteria appear to
cause inflammation which increases the
number of immune cells around the cancer
helping them to homed in on their target
nonspecific immunity can also be
achieved by removing so-called
immune checkpoint blockades these
blockades normally dampen down the
immune response to prevent collateral
damage to healthy tissue but to fight
cancer scientists need to remove some of
these blockades to make the immune
response stronger the antibody
ipilimumab also known as your voi
targets a blockade molecule called
ctla-4 it got FDA approval for patients
with advanced stage melanoma in summer
2011 and it's being tested for several
other types of cancer activating immune
cells inside the body can be difficult
but the next strategy adoptive cell
transfer combat this by extracting the
immune cells from the patient and
activating them outside the body it
enables researchers to specifically
target the cancer tissue one approach is
to take immune cells directly from the
tumor it's difficult to extract enough
cells but the advantage is that the
cells have already learned to recognize
the tumor taking cells from the blood is
much easier but then you've got to use
genetic engineering to arm them with
tumor specific receptors either way the
cells are activated using cytokines and
then multiplied in petri dishes before
being reintroduced to the patient at the
moment this approach is experimental the
fourth strategy uses vaccinations
unlike the BCG vaccine that we mentioned
earlier and which targets the immune
system in a general way these vaccines
are used to direct immune cells very
specifically to the cancer tissue
several viral vaccines have shown
promising results in clinical trials for
example a weakened version of the herpes
simplex virus modified to produce an
immune stimulating factor is being
developed for melanoma and head and neck
cancer it's also possible to vaccinate
with a patient's own tumor cells some
cells are extracted irradiated to stop
them from spread
and then engineered to secrete
activating growth factors when the cells
are injected back into the patient the
growth factors alert the immune system
to the cancer but it's also possible to
vaccinate with a person's own immune
cells for example antigen presenting
cells can be taken from patients matured
outside the body and loaded with tumor
antigen when the cells are reintroduced
to the patient the antigen stimulates
other immune cells and helps them to
recognize the tumor the first vaccine of
this type received FDA approval in 2010
for the treatment of some prostate
cancers it's known as Provenge or
syphilis LT the other vaccination
approaches are still experimental the
last few years have seen many promising
developments in anti-cancer
immunotherapies but there's still much
work to do to help get drugs from the
bench through clinical trials and to the
bedside scientists need to find better
ways to judge the success of
immunotherapies in patients and to work
out the best dose right now it's
difficult to predict who might respond
to a particular treatment and some
responses are only short-lived
if these hurdles can be overcome then
many more cancer patients could benefit
from strategies that boost their immune
system
produced with exclusive support from
Bavarian Nordic and dendron